one man is dead tonight and another is
in the hospital after a shooting in the
central valley this happened around 9 30
last night near desert inn and maryland
parkway that's where we find madison
kimbrough live with the latest in this
investigation madison
yeah sasha police are actually still
here but when police arrived last night
they found a man lying in this alleyway
that you see right here at the sierra
point apartments metro police were then
notified of another victim involved in
the shooting who arrived at sunrise with
a gunshot wound according to officers
those two men got into some type of
argument with an unidentified man that's
when the suspect shot both victims and
then took off the second victim drove
himself to the hospital and remains
there with non-life-threatening injuries
a resident we spoke to of the complex
who doesn't want to be identified says
she knew the victim found in the valley
and excuse me in the alley and she was
the one that made the 911 call
so when i came out the alley he was
laying down on the floor right here so
i'm like i tried to calm her down and
she came because that was her boyfriend
like what the heck just happened
so far metro police have not identified
the victims as for the suspect his
whereabouts are still unknown at this
time reporting near desert inn and
maryland parkway madison kimbrough live
local now